rusia ha sido reiterativo pidiendo a la
otan que acabe con su política de
puertas abiertas sabemos que rechaza un
posible ingreso de ucrania pero esta
solicitud va más allá
pues yo creo que se negocia aquí también
es el futuro jugar arroz ya en el
contexto geopolítico la unión europea
había ofrecido una oferta
de
incluir o roció en la casa europea hace
unos meses y rossi habló de un proceso
siento es muy fuertemente y confrontó
europa entonces este parte
transatlántico si fuere esfuerzo más y
ahora estamos en una situación mucho más
militar y político que antes entonces yo
creo es y bahamas solamente la
pertenencia de la ucrania a la nato pero
también del rol de velocidad en el mundo
que significaría puntualmente para la
otan que cambie su política de puertas
abiertas como lo pierró si esto es
realmente posible sólo por la solicitud
de esta nación
pues hay que entender que hace
30 años
la otan está re limitado hasta la mitad
de alemania expandido
extremadamente hacía en partes que antes
eran socias sin ninguna cuestión o línea
como el báltico y todo esto entonces y
en un contexto externo se puede entender
que roshia se sienta amenazado al otro
lado la situación es así y la
naturalista ha votado que ucrania decide
sobre su propia estructura de seguridad
que provoca el conflicto con roció
obviamente
bueno y rusia está en una posición
defensiva asegura que si hay
intimidación habrá contra intimidación
qué medidas podría tomarnos cuanto más
sanciones internacionales es posible que
se produzca realmente esta invasión en
ucrania que tanto
pues otra vez yo creo tenemos que verlo
en un poco en el contexto geopolítico
del siglo 21 yo veo el conflicto
también en el contexto de lo que pasa
entre las losas de la émula eeuu y china
roshia esta es la tecno ropa y está
acercándose a china y por esto los eeuu
está forzando y empujando los europeos
e
de alejarse mucho de negocio entonces yo
creo que se puede pasar